I woke up with pink hair and matching
tattoos lemme explain
[Music]
[Applause]
I've been alone in New York City now for
just over three months it's 5:30 in the
morning I'm on my way to the airport to
fetch my girlfriend Gabby this is a
pretty big deal for me because we
haven't spent this much time apart in
over two years I got to the airport and
way too then waited some more but that
didn't ruin the moment of seeing you
we drove home then you know I came up
with an idea I really wanted to make a
movie about gaps and I but I'm tired of
all these exploited relationship goal
videos with unrealistic occurrences that
in turn increased subconscious
expectations of the youth skewing their
realities and making their lives in
comparison seem more mundane I never
want to be a filmmaker like that then
how do I create something honest and raw
without a script Aristotle said the aim
artist to represent not the outward
appearance of things but their inward
significance how do I capture what we
share without being guided by the
understanding that someone is watching I
want to create the most real and honest
foam on this planet I set up my most
challenging experiment yet I took to
Twitter to find the most asked questions
about dating a filmmaker then summed up
the best into one question which will be
asked by Gaby's French usually has the
MC Swift but hasn't spoken to in a while
Savannah where in South Africa we send
messages over voice notes if Savannah
could get me one of these from Gabby
[Music]
that was the most emotional thing I've
ever listened to you I'm gonna use that
as the voice-over for our movie from
there I set up an entire fake shoot with
a helicopter a parade and much more we
couch will be my camera system and
hopefully with a little bit of b-roll
performance and what she believes as a
film for the New York Tourism Board then
gave a friend of mine who Gabby believes
Sony's shooting wide cinematic landscape
shots will be secretly shooting real
moments of us together it's three let's
shoot time
[Music]
Hey Dude ah hi miss you your that's a
deep question I don't have any like
social media following or stuff like
that so sometimes I wish that I could
help him and support him more and that
way and give him advice when he asks me
like what I think of a shot or something
I don't know our relationship is
definitely not conventional but we have
this like unwritten agreement that we
just don't plan for tomorrow like the
thought of losing each other it's so
much melancholy to the ecstasy of being
together so just kind of say like the
fact that showed you know but there's so
much that you don't see like he is what
he's like in his films times a thousand
I wish I could film him and show you
I love how crazy he is he's like a
character from an animated movie just
bouncing off the walls I guess he just
inspires me every day I literally have
never met anyone that works so [ __ ]
hard sometimes you'll wake up with like
a name or something so random like a
weirdly specific idea and sometimes
they're actually real and then I see
them like make a film about it a week
later and it's incredible sorry for the
wrong voice in order to actually spoke
to my mom about this before I came but I
think you just kind of have to
understand the relationship that we
share there there's just no expectation
it's like no matter how many times I
have to drive them to the airport to
wake up at 3 a.m. to shoot a time-lapse
or see how the girls wanting to take
selfies with him I'll just continue
because nothing compares
it's just the two of us we just share
the most beautiful friendship and that's
what we are just best friends
sorry I rambled around quite a lot there
but you know what you get
[Music]
[Music]
do you mind if I phones
what I was referring to earlier is an
idea that once happiness levels are
inversely proportional to one's
expectations
gabs and I have such a strong bond
because we don't need expectations to
find our reality everything is relative
I'll never compare gabs and I to anyone
else
so this realisation called for Tatsu and
you're done so we got matching ones
happiness equals reality over
expectation you still don't know this
movies about you they lastly I just want
to sign this form off by saying this
community we're creating here is so epic
and rad and I care about you therefore
don't believe everything you see on
YouTube most of its a lifted truth an
artist's interpretation of something
don't let your expectations shift due to
what seems to be someone else's
realities you're awesome
so just keep on keepin on and then I
guess I'll see you next Wednesday
where I'm hoping to do something
involving the ocean or waves
I need a surf
I'm going crazy
[Music]